(rap music)
(light music)
- [Gary] So, like I know
what I'm trying to do.
I've said it before,
maybe you've heard this.
I'm trying to build the
biggest building in town.
And my big strategy on that
is I'm just going to
build the biggest building.
And I just genuinely believe
that 95% of people that look
like me, their strategy is
to tear down
everybody else's building.
- [Man] Yeah, of course, yes.
- [Gary] And that's it. And
that's why I think I'll win.
'Cause I think I'm capable of
building the biggest building.
(light music)
It's 11:30,
internal meetings all day.
I'm sure Iris has
B-rolled the shit out of it.
Just meeting after
meeting after meeting.
Going to a senior one now.
See ya.
- [Jeff] Hey Gary.
- Hey brother.
- [Jeff] Can you
sign some books?
- [John] Whenever
you wrote Crush It!--
- 2008.
- [John] summarized
exactly where we are today.
- You know, it's really cool
when you put out content or
you write if you end up
being historically correct it's
really, it's very impactful.
You're right. I saw it.
I saw it only because it's
history repeating itself.
Like, I knew this was
gonna become the platform.
When the ground changes,
everything changes.
And so it's not little
shifts, they're big shifts.
There's a very interesting
dynamic with me which is I push
a lot of people to
stop consuming me.
I just want people to
reverse engineer themselves
if they can help it.
I'm amazingly self-aware
and I'm grateful for it.
It's been one of the
drivers of my success.
People struggle with me.
There's something in the way
that I communicate that is
really an incredible
mirror on the other person.
Here's the punch line,
figure yourself out,
love yourself instead of beating
up on yourself 'cause we all
have unbelievable amounts of
shortcomings so why not focus on
what you're decent
at and fucking go do.
I really enjoyed this.
Take care of yourself.
Talk to you soon.
Want to hang for a minute?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Very cool.
- [Woman] Well, you pretty
much like, you're transparent.
- Yeah. I'm very
much in the belief that
why create the
vulnerability of not?
- [Woman] Right.
- Right? It's actually
not practical.
- [Woman] Well, not for you.
- Definitely,
right, that's right.
And you know what,
that's a good point.
And not for anybody in
the world we live in now.
It's hard to hide.
Yo?
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing, Tyler.
- [Tyler] Not confused.
7:30 would be your flight.
- You like that Iris?
You like when
I use my own quotes.
- This has been awesome.
- [Gary] I'm glad.
- I want to hang
out with you more.
- [Gary] You can,
anytime. Reach out.
- [Man 2] What going on, Gary?
- Hey brother.
Good to see you.
You guys want to build your
personal brands or do you guys
want to build the
brand of the company?
- [Man 2] Brand of the company.
Well, everything.
- [Gary] Well, no it's a very,
very, very
important distinction.
Both work. There's a million
reasons to do one or the other.
Personality traits,
how you even feel about,
you may feel the business itself
is positioned in an awkward way
and you actually don't
want to be out in front.
You want to one
day write 40 books.
You want to get paid
$100,000 to give a speech.
I don't know.
Unbelievably, I don't care.
I think that if
I'm gonna help you,
and I want to help you,
that's the first question.
It's a long play.
It will change the
course of your lives.
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody, this
is Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 257
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Jon, real excited you're here.
- Great to be here, Gary.
- And I believe that your show
and you are powerful for that
because I do believe when
I watch it as a person that will
always win in business,
if they listen, they will win.
- Well you know what
I've learned is every failing
business has a
failing owner, Gary.
- It's always the owner's fault.
- So if they
have a failing owner,
after 147 Bar Rescues, you
know guys like you and I learn
everything about success.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- What do you do
to be successful?
- [Gary] Yep.
- The blocks of success.
The planks of success.
After 147 Bar Rescues,
Gary, I've seen the depth
of failure nobody's seen.
- [Gary] Yeah.
(group applause)
Such a pleasure.
- [Jon] A lot of fun.
- That was a lot of fun.
- [Jon] I got to tell you,
I'm gonna do it.
You inspired me.
- You know what?
I believe you.
And what's really funny to me
is you're gonna destroy it.
You're gonna destroy it.
You know, it's the...
You're unlimited.
Listen, it comes natural to you.
You've made a line in
the sand and (snaps) you'll,
I did it with my health, right?
I was like, "I can't, I can't,"
and then I did it and I was
like, "Oh, it's the same shit."
You will crush it.
- [Jon] Thank you, buddy.
- My pleasure, my man.
Continued success.
- [Jon] Same to you.
(light music)
What's up, guys?
9:08 P.M., Tuesday night.
About to have a dinner
with some Vayner Sports peeps.
My episode four of
Planet of the Apps just dropped.
Make sure you check it out.
Binge watch the
first four episodes.
I dominate episode one and four.
Big day of operations.
Just classic
grinder episode of DailyVee.
Nondescript.
The kind of episode that
a lot of us don't remember.
Nobody's gonna talk about.
There's no fucking quote
or amazing moment from it.
Just fuckin'
head down operations,
CEO of a $150 million
Vayner X holding company,
PureWow, VaynerMedia.
And that's just the
way I like it, right?
At the end of the day,
I probably take more pride in
these episodes where
there's nothing crazy.
Oh, you got the,
I put on a suit.
I've got a family wedding.
- [Iris] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So that'll be cool.
Maybe that's the
most descript thing.
But I really enjoy this.
I really want to
suffocate any excuses.
I want to remind people
that this is a real grind,
a real effort.
You know, there's no staging.
There's no nothing.
Just Iris and I
fuckin' living it.
I mean like, Iris--
- [Iris] Yeah.
- literally like
90% of today I was like,
"You can't come to this.
You can't come to this."
- [Iris] I know. (laughs)
- "You can't come to this."
And I'm sorry I can't
share everything with you.
It's peoples private
lives, it's their finances.
It's client stuff, it's I was
reviewing a piece
of business today.
I don't think you guys realize
that 89% of the time you don't
see me is running the business
or spending time with my family.
So you get insight,
you get to see it.
I give you as
much as I can but
fuckin' grinding, you know?
Grinding.
(light music)